Why do today's non-stop shocks --
why don't they spur us into action?
Why don't they produce leaps?
Especially when it comes to climate change.
So I want to talk to you today
about what I think is a much more complete recipe for deep transformation
catalyzed by shocking events.
And I'm going to focus on two key ingredients
that usually get left out of the history books.
One has to do with imagination, the other with organization.
Because it's in the interplay between the two
where revolutionary power lies.
So let's start with imagination.
The victories of the New Deal didn't happen just because suddenly
everybody understood the brutalities of laissez-faire.
This was a time, let's remember, of tremendous ideological ferment,
when many different ideas about how to organize societies
did battle with one another in the public square.
A time when humanity dared to dream big
about different kinds of futures,
many of them organized along radically egalitarian lines.
Now, not all of these ideas were good
but this was an era of explosive imagining.
This meant that the movements demanding change
knew what they were against -- crushing poverty, widening inequality --
but just as important, they knew what they were for.
They had their "no" and they had their "yes," too.
They also had very different models of political organization
than we do today.
For decades, social and labor movements
had been building up their membership bases,
linking their causes together and increasing their strength.
Which meant that by the time the Crash happened,
there was already a movement that was large and broad enough
to, for instance, stage strikes that didn't just shut down factories,
but shut down entire cities.
The big policy wins of the New Deal were actually offered as compromises.
Because the alternative seemed to be revolution.
So, let's adjust that equation from earlier.
A shocking event plus utopian imagination
plus movement muscle,
that's how we get a real leap.
So how does our present moment measure up?
We are living, once again, at a time of extraordinary political engagements.
Politics is a mass obsession.
Progressive movements are growing and resisting with tremendous courage.
And yet, we know from history that "no" is not enough.
Now, there are some "yeses" out there that are emerging.
And they're actually getting a lot bolder quickly.
Where climate activists used to talk about changing light bulbs,
now we're pushing for 100 percent of our energy
to come from the sun, wind and waves,
and to do it fast.
Movements catalyzed by police violence against black bodies
are calling for an end to militarized police, mass incarceration
and even for reparations for slavery.
Students are not just opposing tuition increases,
but from Chile to Canada to the UK,
they are calling for free tuition and debt cancellation.
And yet, this still doesn't add up
to the kind of holistic and universalist vision
of a different world than our predecessors had.
So why is that?
Well, very often we think about political change
in defined compartments these days.
Environment in one box, inequality in another,
racial and gender justice in a couple of other boxes,
education over here, health over there.
And within each compartment,
there are thousands upon thousands of different groups and NGOs,
each competing with one another for credit, name recognition
and of course, resources.
In other words, we act a lot like corporate brands.
Now, this is often referred to as the problem of silos.
Now, silos are understandable.
They carve up our complex world into manageable chunks.
They help us feel less overwhelmed.
But in the process, they also train our brains to tune out
when somebody else's issue comes up
and when somebody else's issue needs our help and support.
And they also keep us from seeing glaring connections between our issues.
So for instance, the people fighting poverty and inequality
rarely talk about climate change.
Even though we see time and again
that it's the poorest of people
who are the most vulnerable to extreme weather.
The climate change people rarely talk about war and occupation.
Even though we know that the thirst for fossil fuels
has been a major driver of conflict.
The environmental movement has gotten better at pointing out
that the nations that are getting hit hardest by climate change
are populated overwhelmingly by black and brown people.
But when black lives are treated as disposable
in prisons, in schools and on the streets,
these connections are too rarely made.
The walls between our silos
also means that our solutions, when they emerge,
are also disconnected from each other.
So progressives now have this long list of demands that I was mentioning earlier,
those "yeses."
But what we're still missing
is that coherent picture of the world we're fighting for.
What it looks like, what it feels like, and most of all, what its core values are.
And that really matters.
Because when large-scale crises hit us
and we are confronted with the need to leap somewhere safer,
there isn't any agreement on what that place is.
And leaping without a destination
looks a lot like jumping up and down.
(Laughter)
Fortunately, there are all kinds of conversations and experiments going on
to try to overcome these divisions that are holding us back.
And I want to finish by talking about one of them.
A couple of years ago, a group of us in Canada
decided that we were hitting the limits
of what we could accomplish in our various silos.
So we locked ourselves in a room for two days,
and we tried to figure out what bound us together.
In that room were people who rarely get face to face.
There were indigenous elders with hipsters working on transit.
There was the head of Greenpeace
with a union leader representing oil workers and loggers.
There were faith leaders and feminist icons and many more.
And we gave ourselves a pretty ambitious assignment:
agreeing on a short statement describing the world after we win.
The world after we've already made the transition to a clean economy
and a much fairer society.
In other words,
instead of trying to scare people about what will happen if we don't act,
we decided to try to inspire them with what could happen if we did act.
Sensible people are always telling us
that change needs to come in small increments.
That politics is the art of the possible
and that we can't let the perfect be the enemy of the good.
Well, we rejected all of that.
We wrote a manifesto, and we called it "The Leap."
I have to tell you that agreeing on our common "yes"
across such diversity of experiences
and against a backdrop of a lot of painful history
was not easy work.
But it was also pretty thrilling.
Because as soon as we gave ourselves permission to dream,
those threads connecting much of our work became self-evident.
We realized, for instance,
that the bottomless quest for profits
that is forcing so many people to work more than 50 hours a week,
without security,
and that is fueling this epidemic of despair
is the same quest for bottomless profits and endless growth
that is at the heart of our ecological crisis
and is destabilizing our planet.
It also became clear what we need to do.
We need to create a culture of care-taking.
In which no one and nowhere is thrown away.
In which the inherent value of all people and every ecosystem is foundational.
So we came up with this people's platform,
and don't worry, I'm not going to read the whole thing to you out loud --
if you're interested, you can read it at theleap.org.
But I will give you a taste of what we came up with.
So we call for that 100 percent renewable economy in a hurry,
but we went further.
Calls for new kinds of trade deals,
a robust debate on a guaranteed annual income,
full rights for immigrant workers,
getting corporate money out of politics,
free universal day care, electoral reform and more.
What we discovered is that a great many of us
are looking for permission to act less like brands and more like movements.
Because movements don't care about credit.
They want good ideas to spread far and wide.
What I love about The Leap
is that it rejects the idea that there is this hierarchy of crisis,
and it doesn't ask anyone to prioritize one struggle over another
or wait their turn.
And though it was birthed in Canada,
we've discovered that it travels well.
Since we launched, The Leap has been picked up around the world
with similar platforms,
being written from Nunavut to Australia,
to Norway to the UK and the US,
where it's gaining a lot of traction in cities like Los Angeles,
where it's being localized.
And also in rural communities that are traditionally very conservative,
but where politics is failing the vast majority of people.
Here's what I've learned from studying shocks and disasters for two decades.
Crises test us.
We either fall apart or we grow up fast.
Finding new reserves of strength and capacity that we never knew we had.
The shocking events that fill us with dread today
can transform us, and they can transform the world for the better.
But first we need to picture the world that we're fighting for.
And we have to dream it up together.
Right now, every alarm in our house is going off simultaneously.
It's time to listen.
It's time to leap.
Thank you.
(Applause)